[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake I'm very excited
to be talking about society and Tec we
have Jeremiah Oh y'all enjoy dance on
the show hey I'm glad to be here thank
you so much for coming on really
appreciate it yeah so pumped for this
conversation Jeremiah's background is
fascinating I'm pumped to jump into
things with your industry we're ports
are just some of the best synthesis of
society in tech and so I love diving
into them and we're gonna unpack those
especially where humanity is going which
is very very cool what's up let's jump
into things with your thoughts on the
overall direction of our world pretty
uncertain pretty scary I think we have a
lot of things to overcome I see a lot of
challenges but this morning I made a
list actually I was thinking about all
the things we overcame is just to last a
hundred years two world wars fascism
you know we're helping to repair the
ozone layer
acid rain Cold War we overcame those so
I know the challenges that are coming
now we can overcome if we work together
what do you think is the one of the most
critical skills for us to embody to make
sure that we can overcome the biggest
challenges together yeah it's thinking
as a collective and right now where a
lot of people are thinking is
individuals the hope is technology can
help unite us but in some cases it's
creating divisions and I think that's
really the opportunity and we need to
think bigger as the planet is it because
it is our home it's our only home we
have one spaceship this is it there's
not enough resources to go to another
spaceship at this moment in time we got
to take care of this one that's what I
think about yeah it's really important
for us to have at least a strong
relationship between our individual
self-actualization as well as the
collective self-actualization
and harmonize those okay let's talk
about you know your journey this is
gonna be cool I wonder how you became so
fascinated with all of these different
fields because I myself am also super
Polymathic in that sense and like how
were you growing up and how did you get
interested in that's a big topic I've
liked that arts and you know media and
as you know I came into your house and I
immediately started to fascinate around
that musical instruments you had here I
love that aspect and then that just just
grew up with a lot of music in my life
and but I became fascinated with new
topics and of course technology and then
I tracked these things so I tracked tech
trends and how they change society for
the good and bad and then what do
society and businesses who tend to be my
customer base you know what do they do
and what should they do and really
that's what I've done yes yes okay so I
see so you kind of have these roots of
being a synthesis when you were younger
and then picking from different fields
and trying to make maybe valuable
insights for people I think you know
that so synthesis is what I'd like to do
it like literally when I see
unstructured things in the world like it
in a market you know I structure them
and you'll see that in my graphics by
the way I don't have OCD I'm not gonna
go and clean your house for you that's
not what I do but I just like to find
the patterns and see if the patterns
repeat sometimes they do sometimes they
don't but often they do and you look
close enough yeah yeah like literally
you can see like the industries
replicate over and over I've seen that
couple patterns now which has been
helpful but also you see how technology
replicates bio structures - thank you so
these these are all related right
networks are networks whether they're
made out of carbon or the made out of
silicon they're very similar yeah
yes yes wow this it seems like it's an
imperative in nature the formation of
just like you illustrate in your
graphics like the collaborative economy
you illustrate in a honeycomb hmm and
for a specific reason
so the honeycomb is nature's one of one
of nature's perfect geometries so you
can put at rest of all there's no wasted
spaces between a hexagon cell right
versus if there were circles you'd have
small little triangles in between them
it's wasted space bees ain't got time to
waste space they're very efficient and
also you can put a lot of weight on a
honeycomb structure unlike a squared
boxed pattern which would collapse it as
just a slight angle so by design honey
combs are one of the strongest and most
efficient structures so that's why I
wanted to organize the market in the
graphic around that because bees have
had it right from millenias yeah so
there's an example of the patterns yes
yes
in this graphic you go and begin showing
how humans have innovated in transit how
they've innovated in food how they've
innovated in health and well-being how
they've innovated in manufacturing I
mean you show all of these different
fields and then you also indicate that a
lot of the time these corporations that
are literally your clients are building
very they're eager to build innovation
but innovation departments and
innovation strategies that are able to
connect them closer to their and
customers the survey so the and
hopefully we can have some links or in
show and the show the honeycomb itself
but essentially the read the second part
of the reason for that module is or for
that diagram is because it's it's many
individuals working together as a
collective and now they're using
technology now so bees they do a number
of ways they have pheromones they also
have a waggle dance
did you know they danced their butts
point the direction of the the flowers
and the pollen and they actually point
certain frequencies and the dance in the
direction which indicates the distance
that the others need to go to find that
so it's this way of working together now
the same thing with tech be shake their
their their tails you see that's perfect
just like that is a perfect raggle dance
they waggle though what they've a go and
they rotate that tells though they're
far away the flower pot that's right and
we had to invent GPS to do what they do
already so perfectly to identify where
is there a shared house where is their
shared ride where is their shared food
where is their on-demand products that I
can borrow or goods and or where can I
get information and it's actually very
similar and they're doing it
peer-to-peer so technology is emulating
that yeah but the technologies were
using our mobile platforms with GPS and
payment systems and we and GPS on a map
is the same thing as that bees doing a
waggle dance and so it's a way of
identifying as we digitize the world
where are the resources that we can
share as a collective as a result
businesses like have emerged and enable
that and the traditional corporations
which are very isolated big corporations
are isolated they're not collaborative
to the network in that safe they make
things and they push them out the door
they're not as connected but digital has
forced them to cut for the ecosystem yes
and as you know and you're really smart
audience and community knows that those
that are connected are more resilient
they have more power right duh duh
they're realizing they have to open the
doors and be connected to the ecosystem
and as a result that means they're now
car companies are renting their cars or
sharing their cars they're emulating
what the qalaat the collective is
already doing hotels are purchasing
their own versions of air B&B
so make homes available for sharing
because they know there's resilience in
being connected to the community so you
can see this pattern of nature is being
replicated by consumer tech yes which is
being replicated by the stoical
industries and institutions that need to
follow what nature's already done yes so
in a way it's I don't know it's
interesting emergent properties that yes
its emergence that these different nodes
in nature independently don't behave in
the same way that when they collectively
the hive of bees collectively behave as
an emergent phenomenon just like when
you know we individually behave
completely differently than when we're
together they have an emergent
phenomenon like this conversation and
like a economy or a government in etc
and so I as we also describe this as
nature and consumer tech basically being
a following very similar principles as
nature does and then corporations also
wanting to then go like the Goliath the
Goliath yeah wanting to go and also yeah
follow those similar trends I also want
to bring up how I think this is this is
critical because we're layering in this
this idea of of this there's a
democratized
future of of getting of what we want
done faster like cities efficiencies
wealth creation mechanisms and all the
different fields and this honeycomb
lattice that you're talking about but
also you see this on like a really
significant the six digital eras
trajectory as well so can you take us
through
this these earlier eras and then where
we're at and where mm-hmm
so yes so a framework I created is
called the six digital errors and at
first the first three eras were very
clear to me ten years ago so in the 90s
and prior to that that we have the
Internet era but it became so dominant
when in the late 90s and this is
basically when in the world people are
creating web pages to say hello I'm out
there it's like a signal like it's like
a small infant you know shouting to to
the world hey we exist and here's my
digital signal you know I always tie
this back to nature by the way those
eras when I was asked to do this report
at Forester as an analyst I I couldn't
figure out what the pattern was so I
went for a walk at Half Moon Bay and and
I walked past the cliffs and I could see
the stratification of that of the
different layers of soil and I said oh
it's Eris and so I said it's Eris so
that signal came there from that walk so
you know these are all intertwined it's
all repeating so that's the first one is
the the Internet era the second era is
the social media era and this is when it
wasn't just for people who had resources
and technical capability to publish
anybody can now admit that signal and
the we saw the rise of YouTube and
Facebook and beyond the third era is
this collaborative economy which is a
peer-to-peer commerce and we've seen
eBay and Airbnb and and lyft and
blockchain and maker movement and
crowdfunding and someone could argue you
Burt does or does not fit into that but
it is enabling some in some regards
peer-to-peer transactions but that's a
whole discussion the next era and so
what we saw now is those become out of
the third era we saw a lot of automation
emerge right
and as self-driving cars and drones and
AI BOTS were integrated into the third
era that gave rise to the fourth era
which is what we call the autonomous
world and that's being tested now
so the first three eras are dominant
well those have come and those are now
part of our world yeah the first one
internet era is kind of dissipated
because it's been some super imposed by
the second third so now we're in the
autonomous era
see self-driving cars sometimes here in
Silicon Valley and we're we chat with AI
bots frequently and every time we use
Google search engine or Facebook
newsfeed that is a that is AI drones are
flying and capturing the footage that we
see in the videos yeah and there's for
sure a ridiculous amount of AI that is
now being developed it's eating our
world so fast and it is and for all
these things that you know are they good
or the bad and my answer is it's fire
fires heat is great and it's also
hurtful it's how we how will the human
wield it it's fire yeah so the next one
is the fifth era is what we call modern
well-being or tech wellness and now the
so the outer world has been digitized
now it's coming inside of us into the in
inner space touch the mic excuse me the
inner space and so like for example this
app will watch as many sensors on it and
there's devices and it's starting to
measure all these things in fact there
are algorithms that could analyze this
video and look specifically at your face
right now and determine which one of the
110 micro expressions you're emitting to
me right now yeah and starts and over
time and you publish a number of videos
get actually start to determine that and
predict what is Allen gonna like or not
like before you actually see something
so that is starting to happen this
modern well-being and determine your
moods my level of tiredness seeing my
mood see my literally the
microvasculature
correct heart rate and the oxygen levels
by the flushing your face those are
things you can see the micro pulsing of
the that can be seen through the our
glasses if there's even a camera facing
you already
so yeah the level of detail how tired
you are how much sleep did you have are
you receptive to new messages at this
moment in time should I be talking to
you about this or that so that can all
you know eventually your brain states
right and I've seen tests of that at
certain conferences like literally a
full chemo electro connectome and your
full biometrics of your heart gut all
being streamed up and processed and
mm-hmm and have basically an AI coach
for all things and this is I like how
you described it as you know digitizing
this outer world and all of our gadgets
and gizmos and mechanics and automation
stuff and now this inner world modern
well-being is like how can we leverage
these incredible computational
capacities for doing things like like
this idea of like mood or this idea of
education or self-actualization or
longevity right yes and these are
wonderful things and horrible things
because if you look at the last two eras
right the autonomous world actually is
all all the eras many of them been
co-opted and you know they're either
owned by the 1% or they have become the
1% the promise of the collective owning
these things actually hasn't panned out
and I've seen this pattern enough times
so we actually need to question when we
are collecting this bio-data around us
or the mood data or emotion data who's
using it and how you know is it really
free if I get these services and this
app you really need to start questioning
that because that isn't concern agreed
there's a big gap that we still need to
fill that for right now it's that we own
none of our data and in the future we
want to all own our data own data and be
able to control the anonymize it and
send it up for processing but also open
up these flows and or is it gonna be all
completely transparent is it gonna be
quantumly encrypted there's all these
questions that are being asked like well
we have to hide or going to restructure
like the way we think about ownership I
mean who really owns the air I mean data
is like the data second right and we're
breathing it in we're adding to it we're
extrapolating from it we're using it the
trees reading who owns it and data might
be that pervasive to so it's but yes I
know there's air rights in places like
Manhattan yes I know there's air quality
within certain I get that but who really
owns that air in this room yeah
no this is this is a question this is a
great question maybe the the answer of
this could be like nature or something
and then would you then be able to say
something like you know maybe like
Facebook having this oculus that brings
me into a world in a couple decades
that's completely indistinguishable from
this world do they then become my nature
and they then own the air in this sense
and so that's a big question ask a
digital trainer of this reality right
yes and those are things that are that's
gonna happen on our generation as well
yeah and in designer realities as well
ones that don't look anything like this
planet this digital twin of the planet
because people are so creative and if I
can manipulate bits faster than I can
manipulate atoms I'm gonna just click
and delete this pillow faster than like
how do I delete this physical pillow
like you know and then I just want to
jump between these designer virtual
worlds and so for my inner well-being I
want to do things like let's give let's
give some good examples for for the
audience sure well let's talk about data
types because that is what is driving
the apps and then the business models
for better or for worse it's just that
is like a trigger and and that's why I'm
often I am a tech analyst so the tech
triggers something and it's unfortunate
it's not the other way around where it's
what is our needs
then let's develop the technology
usually it's here's a technology let's
figure out how it impacts society oops
we make a mistake there which has
happened many times in tech okay all
right so the common ones now are kinetic
movement right so tracking your movement
and location and then the second is
heart rate so people are using this and
there was a report recently from
Stanford partner with Apple and they use
a heart rate variability data to track
it to see if people had irregular heart
murmurs and this was to help stave off
heart attacks and other cardiac diseases
I think that's a wonderful thing
of course there's also genomics and
genetics tracking I'm not an expert in
that space but that's a way if I
everybody collectively contributes to
that is to help predict disease if not
fight it so that's an interesting thing
as well yeah yeah and I'm hoping that
with the inner well-being digital era
that we're currently um that we're
currently getting into that I hope that
people can be creative longer and
flourish better on a moment-to-moment
basis and and I hope that AI coach can
just like come in and say you know hey
Allen you know you're only gonna get six
hours of sleep if you go to bed right
now right so that's in a way starting to
happen who knows more about you Apple
well I don't know a device system you're
on ok Apple or Google order your doctor
right oh I think right now it's really
clear that yeah yeah
and so those way and most people see
their doctor healthy people see their
doctor once a year if that and they take
a quick snapshot of their body with the
physical if they if they do that many
people are averse to that but they're so
willing to give up this bio-data a
tremendous amount of bio-data that we
don't even for example their sensors in
the Apple watch they haven't told us
about yet so we think there's oxygen
level data that's already being pooled
and there's just a lot of in your blood
and breath data can be tracked by the
movement micro movements as you wear
earbuds - mmm right so yeah so there's a
tremendous amount of information so yes
an 8 to bring bring that back in AI
coach - it's like a therapist it's a
doctor it's a pharmacist it's it's a
psychologist all of its a mentor it's a
friend it's all those things but but is
that is that the human condition that we
want should should we be relying on
those devices and that tech I mean some
people are developing anxiety right now
if they see oh I only have a yellow band
versus a green on the amount of sleep I
had last night I'm gonna have a pretty
crappy day today the self-fulfilling
prophecy of anxiety
you know and some people have anxieties
they'll get enough steps and so this
unique reliance on technology is
creating adverse effects as well as
beneficial ones so again it's fire which
way we will use it I love your
perspective on that it's actually
integrating philosophy into your
synthesis of technology and being an
industry analyst and and what you get by
doing that is you get the the question
of can you identify all of those
instances when people feel like the AI
coach is absolutely helping them
significantly and other instances when
maybe it's actually hurting them in some
way and so I think that's a that's a
that's a really tough question and how
do we find the data as the answer that's
the fifth one then there's this sixth
one we kind of we started getting into
the VR one a little bit the digital
realities but there's also going off
this era yes so going back to our
original framework and this one's fuzzy
and we're just kind of tracking it but
it's called off world or off planet or
off the planet and it started with
obviously there's SpaceX and a number of
organizations and Blue Origin that are
trying to get humans off the planet but
the trend that I was tracking is now
satellites are now being shared yeah and
this is wonderful and scary at the same
time and we're seeing that Amazon wants
to enable a shared satellite network
that could be the data can be pulled
down to the Amazon Cloud and businesses
or maybe individuals could purchase that
data so how could that be used right now
if somebody like many people are
spending money on nest or are low or
Google home that for security how much
would somebody pay to have a satellite
watch their house at night and if there
were people intruding where it
automatically call the authorities you
know so I'll bet you that'll be used a
some people will pay that or a drone
fleet also it's not as efficient as the
satellites that are already up there yes
already standing millions of problem and
they have infrared and they can see
through clouds and smoke and so can be
used for disaster recovery it could use
to be tracked at Agrico
agricultural health you can actually
look at supply chain like say I I said I
purchase beef from this farm how those
animals being treated you could
potentially zoom in and or you could see
which countries or companies are
actually are they upholding their
promise to the environment you can zoom
in on their factories or their plants
and actually see that in which where is
pollution coming from and what is the
state of the conditions of the oceans or
whatever it so the amount in a real time
right not just a snapshot so that level
of detail is starting to come in so
that's as much as I'm looking into this
space so that so the the big trend
across all six of these things is that
every aspect and that's outer space
right yeah and so every aspect of the
world in society is becoming digitized
and people are making sense of that
creating powerful AI so there's a
tremendous amount of information that's
being found and then people are creating
businesses for good and bad and it's
just accelerating the world in amazing
ways and scary ways hopefully you're
hearing the duality out of main course
yeah just a loss of four things well I I
don't consider myself that but it's you
know it you have to look at it because
the promise right when social media
first arrived and I was very active in
the scene here in Silicon Valley fifteen
years ago we said this is going to make
the world free and transparent and and
everybody will have a voice and then we
found out that it has significant
political ramifications like that we can
see it right today right and the world
so that's in mental health and
well-being really yes yes and to and
negative
most of the social network apps are
deleted off my phone right now exactly
like what yeah we know that we're more
likely to just get distracted by them
from our ideal a North Star pursuit then
from then just an you oh I'm just gonna
just post one thing
it's always something you're addicted to
that yes and I also like the way that
Benny office where that is actually kind
of stepping up and talking about the
future of capitalism being around
technology basically doing what you're
talking about right now which is
identifying when fire is being used in
the best purposes to cook our food and
to warm our houses and stuff like that
rather than burn mm-hmm each other and I
think he's a model he is a model leader
yes I do of that yeah yeah and in in in
many ways you know you know what Bill
and Melinda Gates have done or like what
the Chan Zuckerberg initiative trying to
trying to do as well I think these
things are it's not clear exactly how as
in the six digital eras there's been a
massive accumulation of wealth for a few
for a few but the standard of living has
also gone up for those as well it's not
clear the bottom has rised faster it's
it's actually pretty clear that the top
has rised faster at the bottom slowly
rising to but the ones that go all the
way to the top it's not clear how to
best use those resources in order to
maximize civilizational prosperity and
so we're kind of running permutations
creatively to figure out okay well
probably not just giving the government
the money there's gonna be a lot of
other stuff that happens there that's
bits but also not hoarding it and buying
six yachts okay okay okay we're setting
to feel it out maybe a little like
private public partnership organizations
that focus heavily on a specific
objective like like mapping the inside
of a cell or figuring out when it's at
the center of the black hole or mapping
the whole chemo Electric Connect dome or
eradicating Alzheimer's there's like
whoa so like you know how do we do that
how do we run those little tiny of
the wealth creation that's happening
from this the six digital eras this and
and how we can best collab this kind of
goes to your first point I am sorry I
have really agree with your the way you
described it that the overall the
collective good has gone up and I agree
with that
you know it's also brought awareness to
areas that are not being lifted up but
we should also remember that only half
of the planet is on on the internet so
we still have a significant digital
divide us anticipating we would talk
about this so I'm glad that we did go
through more of your songs yeah
very there are a few that are extremely
wealthy and they will remain wealthy I
don't see that changing in particularly
the sharing economy I was part of this
small group of true believers optimist
that you know had this idea that the it
would decentralize all power and I said
that didn't happen in the social media
space it actually created a new class at
one percenters Mark Zuckerberg and Jack
Dorsey and the investors in those
companies had to happen again so that I
seen that I'm seeing that pattern
replicate it so having a reward for
innovation and entrepreneurs who take
great risk is a great thing but at what
level do they need and and make sure
that the so right now too I created a
post talking about the class system that
we have and we actually have we really
do have this like this medieval caste
system so at the highest level are the
the kings and in today's society and
Silicon Valley that is the investors the
kings would grant the land to the Lords
which would be the castle and that which
they can run that feudal system and then
from there those are the entrepreneurs
and they create their little castles and
kingdoms and if they invite you to come
be workers then you can now if you
cannot identify with the Lord or the
King which is investor or the CEO then
you are a peasant or a pawn or
at the very bottom level and so or me
and as well so that exists yet again
it's digital feudalism damn yeah Wow
whoa Wow it's in this kind of is the
same way you portray this digital
feudalism I think other we've also had
this conversation about modern-day
slavery that I'm not
what do you mean freedom what freedom
are you talking about we will we spend
50% of our waking hours working for
people to make money to pay for things
that we don't even necessarily need
sometimes and so yes there's a whole
it's very true there's a whole that
ecosystem of minus a plus this digital
feudalism that's happening where it's
like I mean just telling someone that
you buckle up and go and you know become
an entrepreneur it's like how does that
actually happen in today's in today's
world and it's like every day have your
ideas and make them have your ideas and
make them day after day after day after
day and after ten years maybe your ideas
will still be around and people will
find them to be very valuable and then
you can start getting a little bit of
money and you can start getting a little
bit of a team and then you know that's
kind of like this dream that we paint of
creativity and entrepreneurship now but
there's still a serious hierarchy
Ceri it's a hierarchy president I don't
think that's going to change unless
there's serious changes at the highest
federal levels and using federal levels
you think that like I could could
certain aspects like the decentral the
future of decentralization technologies
could potentially open up like the way
that the current Federal Reserve has
like a choke on our throats on money and
now in ten years you're like whoa
Bitcoin aetherium cryptocurrencies is
like so interestingly enough all of a
sudden that they're like oh god we're
losing our grip on that which is kind of
interesting so maybe there's other ways
that people have the grips and have
without big moats that are going to
collapse because of them hmm
technologies like this it's so I think
that was a cryptocurrencies the first
wave we saw as a test there's going to
be something else that emerges that that
was just the test something else will
happen I mean we learned a lot from that
that was helpful
but even without getting too political
that the number of the political
Democratic candidates in the United
States espouse the the beliefs of shared
wealth and many of them want to regulate
big tech so as their positions and
platforms whether they do or not is
another topic or if they get elected but
you can see that's starting or andrew
yang who was on your show and i've sat
down had coffee with them so he believes
in that as well so you can see at least
three candidates are starting to bring
that up yeah and in the echo system so i
think this conversation when we continue
is is reducing the digital divide
amongst the masses so we'll see yes this
is another potentially an actually an
interesting industry report to create or
for other people to create is around a
wealth accumulation from the six
additional eras now that's pretty yeah
what the patterns are already clear to
me but and and then also the the optimal
formats of allocating reallocating
resources towards collective prosperity
what is the maximization protocol the
best objective function and that's a
that's a great question actually I want
to ask you that exact question what do
you think is the purpose of the human
experience that's very deep I'm and I
don't feel like I know
that's a very good question I don't have
an insightful answer I'm still trying to
figure out what that is like
and
if you were to maybe think about your
own pursuit and your own towards your
own Northstar in this world what has
given you the most idea of what is the
meaning of your life in your existence
so bigger than just work or looking at
trends I personally love challenges and
I think I think there's the growth comes
in the pain and the struggle and the
suffering for example when you picked up
my backpack you notice there's a bunch
of weights in there 25 pounds that load
out is 20 pounds and and that you makes
my bones denser in and gives me better
posture and strengthens muscles and it's
annoying to pick it up but then after a
while you forget it's there and it's
just because parties I love the testing
and on how to accomplish new things and
so I just love that part of the human
conditioning is suffering for growlithe
mm-hmm yeah I like that I like
challenges challenge it's like you know
um I I had a corporate job but I've been
independent for 10 years so I took the
risk to go be an entrepreneur which is
kind of the norm around here in the Bay
Area but that was a risk I put my family
at risk put me at risk I didn't know if
it's going to work
but I do love those types of challenges
to try that what has been your
relationship with
source or God or all that is or you know
what is be your connection to this
higher essence I think a lot about the
collective and I mean that if you look
at the the thread of all of the research
have done is like how are we connecting
is as one unit but I'm looking at how
how we're all one interconnected that
that's and I'm not really able to
articulate it as well as I am in a tech
market because it's not something I'm
mastery often actually probably one of
the most important principles of that
source or God or all that is
conversation is literally
interconnectedness of all things all
things not just humans not just you
that's right yeah yeah and okay and how
about us for young children I have three
three three three children
are any of them big teenage yet no
they're very young very low to 10-ish
yeah okay what would you recommend for
your own children and for those watching
and their children for some sort of a
way to succeed in this digital
technology explosion into society and
and beyond just tech so I'm trying to
teach my young ones and other kids as
well as the ability to learn so all of
these the information is there and it's
going to be public and there's vast
amounts of it but being able to discern
what really matters and then able to
make those decisions is going to be key
and to quickly learn so I've been
teaching my children like how to learn
and constantly learn and relearn rather
than just relying on rote memorization
which is traditional and American that's
changing now in American public schools
when I grew up and perhaps when you grew
up but now they're starting to teach
them how to find their own ideas and I
think that's a change that we need to
embrace in society because things are
moving more dynamically and the pace of
change is accelerated in all aspects
from politics to the environment to
sustainability to societal issues and
technology new releases they're moving
at a faster everything's oscillating at
a faster pace the frequencies have
gotten higher and higher now right we're
versus a hundred years ago the
frequencies were lower bands right so
we're moving into the upper registers
and it's it has a lot of tension so you
have to teach the children to quickly
jump from wave lengths the wave lengths
that are oscillating at a fast pace it
is stressful and that is what to do it
so to answer your specifically is is
learning in multi disciplines yeah so
I'm encouraging and inviting my children
to learn from at least in outside of
school and at least 3 domains want a
stem so one of my children is already
playing with Lego robotics right and we
do math together and
and the other one is is is fitness and
movement and taking care of your body
the physical sense
so we participate in things related to
that and the third one is the humanities
and we do art or dance or music we play
piano and so on try to have that
different disciplines together and we're
always learning from those as well you
know there's something that can combine
all of them that would be amazing and
it's pretty rare but so that's the
specific way I think about that I love
that and have maybe the to kind of add
into maybe the humanities a bit and have
the two other ones I've been to the
fitness one a little bit into the stem
one a bit just to like you know grow the
overall Ultima Neri whole human tool
belt yeah for them um I also like how
you talked about it as an overall over
thymus and Ascension process and the
frequencies increasing and in a sense it
kind of reminds me like oh people are
like young people can't attention they
can't focus I don't think well there may
be some sort of a truth to like yeah
long periods of focus on specific
objectives that you want to solve that's
totally true but at the same time in the
sense with this ascension that we're
talking about to be like vigilant of
okay I'm focusing my time on this thing
but then something else comes up am I
able to quickly and efficiently switch
to the thing that I have to focus on now
to solve this other big challenge in a
completely different field that's also
the other thing could it be even in a
completely different field and then to
go back while managing other people in
my own health and working with this AI
coach all at the same time so you have
to in a sense be able to hold a bunch of
different things in your worldview
tones and variables and this next
generation may not even think of it as
switching like mental switching it's I
think that's actually how they they kind
of grow up is it just multi-channel on
all the time like they probably three
screens on at a time right
a real wearable device found and I don't
even think they're gonna use a laptop
it's probably a verbal based AI right
yeah which is that's what Amazon is
pushing his voice in audio yeah right
and then they have the mobile device
which itself is disappearing and
dissipating as well Amazon last week
announced or two weeks ago announced
that they have glasses now which have
six microphones on them right so you can
see and a half you know you can see
where this is going it's going all
around us but and the screens are slowly
dissipating away yeah correct exactly
getting yeah it's all you have voice
playing in these 3d environments with my
voice in my hands yeah yeah so screens
disappear but I think that's like what
we will know when we truly are mobile
first as we don't even see the mobile
device and so that that's where we're
headed and there's so many other
incredible reports that you guys have
that we could talk about but I just
highly recommend people to to go to the
website and check on my web - strategist
comm um callate Oh Clyde Oh in salina
like kaleidoscope collide Oh insights
Oh calm and your Twitter profile as well
check out those reports they are so
incredible check out the blog post
everyone there so so good what another
one was on like autonomous vehicles and
other one was on what the corporate I
guess we wouldn't we have to at least
ask you this question as well I
shouldn't have to ask you what are
corporations doing inside of their
buildings inside of their processes that
are facilitating the greatest amount of
innovation development so let's use a
metaphor so the corporations are
traditionally like large stone blocks
immobile rigid cold now they're
realizing they need to be more like a
redwood forest still strong but they
bend in the wind and a whole host to
many other organisms many which are
unseen beneath the soil and they enable
life around
and in a connected ecosystem and so that
that's the mindset shift that they
realize they need to behave like the
tech startups if you look at the popular
tech startups they enable life around
them for example Facebook who's creating
the content everybody else but Facebook
they're enabling that Apple who creates
the apps not really Apple you know their
primary revenue line is selling phones
second is the App Store and iTunes and
you can go on and on it and uber who's
actually doing the work the crowd
Airbnb whose homes are they their crowd
so but in order to do that they need to
be agile nimble and have in a way a
mindset of enabling the ecosystem
lifting up the ecosystem around you
rather than being the sole beneficiary
yes that's right
interesting stood like the moving from
the stone to the redwood to deal with
all of the wind of the movement for the
tree but also as a redwood then maybe
doing something like creating shade for
others to come back lay stuff like that
exactly and and it's an interconnected
ecosystem right and even there's life
under the soil and they're and they're
connected to other organizations and
even to other large companies so
everything is becoming connected through
digital and it's good to get specific
api's and data right that and so that's
resulting in this the resilience so to
be very specific big companies are
trying to be agile and nimble right that
and their means they have to be welcome
to trying new things that often result
in failure and that is very difficult
traditionally if a stone breaks it
splinters in half and they and it feels
not very great I don't know how stones
feel but I'm just trying to take that
metaphor a little as far as I can and so
the failure was not really an option for
these big corporations and now they're
realizing they have to place lots of
tiny little bets yes and do that so
they're running the permutations the
creative decisions but also they're
creating platforms that enable other
people screens and need to come through
them that's right and that could be
either their own employees with a
innovation
entrepreneurship program intrapreneur
intrapreneurship is like if they have
that day off every week Friday off it
should be infused throughout the whole
process so it shouldn't be just
interesting not just a day off but maybe
while you work whenever you feel like it
transition to the it not transition it
should be part of always growing the
existing product yet so when you when
you talk to the the big tech startups
Google Amazon they don't have innovation
departments the big traditional company
have innovation departments run by a
specific person because they were not
innovative to begin with so it can
automotive manufacturer used to just
slight permutations on each product
which was part of the product roadmap
that's actually not innovation that's
just permutations so innovation to
create up something completely new that
comes from another group and it's
because they have been disrupted by the
tech startups let me give you a
practical example the car companies are
now doing a ride-sharing or car sharing
or they're preparing for rides as a
service so you can order them through an
app on a membership they're preparing
for that because uber disrupted them
five years ago so badly that they
realized that they themselves need to
become innovative yeah and so they're
now thinking oh in the future we don't
sell cars we're just offering a mobility
service yeah so that's innovative
thinking versus product iteration is ah
we need to make the ride more
comfortable we need to have more miles
per gallon oh we need more comfortable
seats
yeah that's not innovation that's just
iteration so they actually had to be
completely just intermediated by uber
and lyft car sharing or ride-sharing for
them to realize oh wow we have to really
think a lot different whoa so it's a
pressure cooker sometimes happens and
then the it goes from iteration to
innovation that's right and so the
definition we use of innovation we
interviewed people with that title is
doing something new that solved customer
needs and it's probably in conflict with
your existing business model
the last part yeah that serves the
customers needs but then it's also in
conflict with the existing bismallah
yeah right cuz that's kind of what it
feels like when we also take on
something else is like in a sense it's
like oh but we're focusing so much of
our attention here and we're making you
know 80% of our revenues from just the
20% of stuff here we want to keep
focusing on it but it's like yeah but
then you have your blinders on to what
all these other possibilities are that
if you hedged a bunch of different bets
that one of those could become your next
one percent of the that's right it makes
90 percent of your revenue that's right
yeah and so that's why it can't be just
something you do once a day inside of a
company but that that culture of
innovation has to be infused to the
whole organization like you'll see this
in the leadership principles at Amazon
you'll see this at the Google 8020 rule
which is what you're sort of referencing
you'll see the set of dobie with their
intrapreneurship programs so yeah so
it's starting to take hold and other
organizations as well I love that so it
intrapreneurship is actually a very
crucial principle of innovation
especially at these bigger yes
operations and so that means that the
ideas come from all levels of the
company
not just from product managers yeah we
can be from any in there yeah yeah so
that's part of this whole back to the
bigger theme here is the connectedness
and how the the crowd is empowered and
how we're all connected so yeah yeah
whoa
okay and then just last last couple
questions do you think that this is
already a simulation I love this topic
and I've read the the articles and I've
listened to the the podcast and watched
the YouTube videos and yeah it's
statistically yeah it's probably a
simulation we're probably not basically
base layer base reality yeah
statistically where it's not
but who am I to say I was already
programmed to say that I love that that
thought yeah so have you played SimCity
oh yeah okay yes I love that game and
there's a moat after you build your
beautiful city right and it's got all
these yeah it maybe it's in tune with
nature maybe it's high-tech
you can choose one of the disasters
right whether it's like UFOs or
tornadoes or fires or riots and it seems
like this year like the player just hit
a bunch of the hoes all that would have
everything but the UFO is coming yeah I
guess that's next you have to be a geek
to really know I guess yeah actually
putting ourselves in that creator
perspective of the reality is one of the
best ways I think also for kids one of
the best skills for them because then
they gain this world view understand
exactly looking at systems and patterns
and holistic and the connectedness
that's exactly that is a great Sid
Meier's also civilization that's a great
way does it look at that as well
like look from look down on the
universe's on our planet and on the
civilization and how everyone's behaving
and stuff from the top from the top down
and then see that systems perspective
see the interconnectedness perspective
and look bottom up from like the like
plonked the atom like up yeah yeah yeah
and that's tied to yeah even in this
room there's a tech system which layers
up to the other tech systems in other
neighborhoods which become the societal
digital web right and which is the
Internet right so you can look at it
both ways yeah yes
yes yes and humans are right in the
middle between the smallest and the
biggest or right in the middle last
question what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
a new life
why
these are core instructions and core DNA
code as create new life yeah
I mean it's when you look at the human
behavior it's it's to procreate and I
don't just mean I don't just mean to
have children you know it's to help
other people grow as well or its plants
or its or its or its a pet like we get
so much joy on a new life it is part of
our core instruction yes and survival
instinct
I mean it's those that couldn't do it
are not here in all parts of biology and
the ecosystem so I think that's
beautiful
who on the hierarchy of priorities new
life is probably at the top oh you know
cool you get the air and the water and
the food but you know making new life
and being with new life is and you get
three of them Matt you're your own new
life that yes I do and that is uh that
is a joy in it and it does things see
you that yeah being a dad is one of the
coolest experiences of life and her mom
yeah and then especially when they have
kids and you be cool grandpa or grandma
hold on there you really see the cycle
of life happening and then you're like
whoa yeah yeah Jeremy thank you so much
whew
that was so deep for conversation was so
great thank you I'm so happy you have
incredible knowledge about society and
technology and its in capacities to
synthesize and disseminate which is
something that we love so much so this
has been an honor for us as well thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations to your friends
families co-workers people online about
society and technology about all of
these systems about the
interconnectedness of them and about the
future of them and about how you
yourself can become more actualized and
collectively actualized together check
out all the links in the Bible of web
strategist com also Cola collide Oh
insights calm and and also Jeremiah's
Twitter profile go and check out those
industry reports they are incredible
they'll give you extremely valuable
insights go check those out everyone
also shout-out to Ori Shapira our
co-producer thank you very much Ori they
we appreciate it and also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the leaders in
your communities and organizations that
you believe in because you can support
us to look below look in the links below
support us help us grow as well help all
those leaders grow around you and go
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon peace
[Music]